dang it's your old pal uncle hank thank
you for subscribing to our youtube page
if you haven't subscribed
hit that subscribe button so you get the
episodes as they come out
also we are now out on our own and all
of the episodes are available here on
your youtube page
or wherever you listen to podcasts and
also make sure you sign up for our new
patreon at patreon backslash are you
garbage
to get additional bonus content we love
you and thank you
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage the show we sit
down with your favorite comedians
in if they grow up classy or if they're
absolute trash i'm your host dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful
fall day here in new york city
from gas digital studios in the big
studio
could not be more excited here in the
east village my co-host coming at you
from right [ __ ] next to me he's white
knuckling it right now he's got
something stewing in him
he's burying some emotions down i can
tell you that this kid's ready to blow
but gang you know the drill the next
time you're reaching for a best pal you
go ahead and make it a kippy
give it up for my best friend in the
world i love you buddy you're setting me
up for something i don't [ __ ] like
this
kevin james ryan gang hey what's up
everybody
thanks so much for tuning in as always
please make sure
you rate review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube you can
subscribe there as well and also
www.patreon.com
are you garbage yes sir check it out
we're on our own
gang i need this we could not be more
excited to have our incredibly
incredibly incredibly big baby
he's a [ __ ] huge get he's tuning in
all the way from the coast
via 5g satellite technology brought to
you by gas digital studios
uh he is a very successful stand-up
comedian writer podcaster and actor
you've seen him in crashing uh he's
written on the burn with jeff
ross he's written on the roast of james
franco justin bieber
rob lowe and the [ __ ] king bruce
willis
you've seen him on roast battle he
worked on brody stevens enjoying it you
seen him on last call with carson daly
at midnight the joe rogan experience he
has his own special out called one shot
and of course the incredibly successful
host
of kill tony gang do me a favor
give it up for the kid the one the only
tony hinchcliffe everybody look at him
[ __ ] home studio [ __ ] things on
the wall this guy's successful
that's it this is it this is as big as
success
i mean you got the old am radio mic
right there you look like you're calling
a [ __ ] ball game in the 40s that
thing's quality
abso [ __ ] literally man i tried to
get i tried to get the shittiest [ __ ]
pop first thing on amazon that uh
that pops up yeah i did the same thing
it was like 9.99 i'm like this'll do
oh the beginning of the quarantine we
were all scrambling like we were howard
stern to get [ __ ] the feeds up and
running yeah i like the two big wheels
that reeled a reel going and [ __ ] in my
house
looking like a [ __ ] idiot oh no [ __ ]
buddy thanks so much for [ __ ] uh
coming on with us man we appreciate it i
know the fans appreciate it
everybody has been [ __ ] asking for
you
and we couldn't be more excited because
no one's more garbage than me i'm going
to convince you guys i promise you think
so
i i you know i know a little bit about
you i feel like you really you really
take care of yourself now you might have
really came from garbage
but you you run a tight ship it seems it
seems like you run a really tight
trigger
kid dress is nice i've never seen you a
couple of times over the years
uh like if you pop into the stand or
somewhere in the city
always had a fresh tight leather jacket
on nice jeans looking fresh
yeah but you think you're going i guess
that's really what i'm claiming is i
might be one of the
most recovered former garbage people
it's like when uh
you know it could be like the uh robert
downey jr almost
sure yeah yeah a good second hand
garbage was drawn
and now i'm like scraps for little kids
yeah his mom was a two-door stick
just got back from pebble beach this
weekend been golfing up and down the
coast
of california driving my corvette i mean
i'm sort of and now i'm like
old guy garbage but i used to just be
straight right wait a minute that's what
you roll in you have a corvette
yeah that's that's that's new money
trash
holy [ __ ] man that's ricky bobby level
that's like you get a couple of bucks
and you don't know how to spend it i
love it
wait what year is the corvette 2019
oh what color is it it's black
black with two little bruce lee yellow
stripes
holy [ __ ] this guy's the [ __ ] a team
i like it
driving around like face man that's a
transformer car damn that's
nuts uh you had to have come from
garbage the [ __ ]
to that's that's your big problem when
you when when trashy people get money
the first car
is always a dead giveaway well
yeah well i i feel like real trash like
is like there's a difference between
just trash trash and stupid trash right
stupid trash would go for a mustang
yeah that's what i'd be catching
i'd be looking for an iraqi yeah
exactly you gotta splurge the extra six
ten fifteen thousand
dollars and get the real [ __ ] car now
is that your only car or is that
is that your your fun car oh yeah yeah
yeah no i don't have one i don't need
like some truck i don't live like that
lifestyle so you're showing up to the
grocery store in a [ __ ] vet
yeah you can't get a camping case of
water in the back seat
yeah nowhere you got to buy a six-pack i
don't know if you guys know how this
works but people that
yeah you don't have to go to the grocery
store yourself anymore
that's classy that's classy well we're
new york so we gotta go but still
i just told you about the vet you think
i'm walking through a ralph's what are
you talking about
[Music]
all the money that we make that's just
how it works that's the rule
dude that's awesome that's my favorite
answer so far dude getting a [ __ ] vet
i can't even bring my i can't believe in
this real i noticed this a lot during
the pandemic because it's like
why are i just i've never understood for
like two years now
loading water and stuff like toilet
paper and paper towel like it's so
it's so dumb if you're not on amazon
prime right now you're just
you're just not even a human being yeah
you got to really
not be trying yeah if you got a case of
water in your
trunk your trash i'll tell you that i
got i got one that i'll take some out of
every now and then like a real piece of
garbage
and they say it's real bad to keep those
plastic bottles in a hot car because the
micro plastics just leak into the water
dude my mom has been slowly poisoning my
family for the last 10 years because
every summer
there's a case of water sitting in the
back of the car for [ __ ] three days
yeah she's a classy broad holy [ __ ] all
right so
dude that car says so much i can't wait
to hear about uh
about your upbringing i feel i feel like
one of your parents had to be john
cougar mellencamp
for you want to get a [ __ ] vet
so where did you grow up yeah where did
you grow up
youngstown the salt of the earth baby
that's like the epitome of salt of the
earth youngstown
what do you know about what do you know
about youngstown
yeah that it's like um the heart of
america baby cold hard
steel and miller light commercial yeah
keep nose to the grindstone blue collar
and then
there was some mob activity too i think
there you go yep that's that's what i'm
fishing for because uh the mob it's the
central meeting place between new york
and chicago
so a lot of the biggest mobsters and uh
really a lot of the most important
people um
back in the day used to set up central
camps in youngstown so it became like
the third highest concentration
of um italian people for a long
time in america and what ended up
happening is a lot of mafia stuff so
yeah it was the biggest steel producing
city in the world and when all that went
down in like and it all happened all at
once was a big deal in youngstown
they were the largest steel producing
city in the world and then overnight
they were nothing
and organized crime really ran rampant
because all these guys had uh
no jobs they were looking to make money
any way they could whether it was
betting on football games and all that
and uh
um and as you guys know uh you know
those mafia guys
fridays are for the girlfriends and
saturdays or for the wives or whatever
you're saying yeah
yeah and that's what um that's
basically in a big way what my mom was
to my father they were both married with
separate families
and had entire families so
my mom and my dad uh
actually were banging it out with each
other for 11 years
11 years on the side with no one finding
out
and then my mom yeah my mom has four
kids i have four older brothers and
sisters
my the closest one is 12 years older
than me
that's my brother and then a sister 14
years older than me a brother
16 years older than me and a sister 18
or 9 or 20 years older than me dude when
you get into double digits it's it's a
bad look
absolutely you have to come back from
the double digit age spread
i'm very excited i'm just beginning here
and there's two
uh older siblings on the dad's side so
they already were like done making
families they're
the same thing like 12 and 14 years
older than me too
so they were done making families but
you know in such an italian
sort of community you don't like you
know divorce is the last
option so they're you know sleeping in
separate beds from their husbands and
wives
they're you know it's just a whole
different operation
and my mom got knocked up they took a
a little vacation to niagara falls which
goes to show you what kind of garbage
we're doing
did they go to the wax museum holy [ __ ]
wait so was your dad a connected guy
he yes i can talk about it now because
he's not so no point in researching
anyone on the internet
sure damn you know what i mean so
yeah so he was so your mom was his gumad
oh that was [ __ ] romantic [ __ ]
situation well
it's funny you say that because it
really is and they both can't you know
they were never together together they
never got together
and they are completely madly even
though they would never admit it
in love with one another they can
sometimes they sort of admit it if you
get enough wine in one of them
the lasagna is good enough you know what
i mean yeah but they're like never
together so
uh i think my dad maybe assumed that my
mom
would get an abortion but that was never
an option so she had me at 38. in fact
uh this is one of the the one of the
only points that i was able to
really think about that i wanted to
mention to you guys was that
my oldest sister who's i like i said
either 18 or 20 years older than me
that's crazy so check this out you ready
for this
she was pregnant with her first child
while my mom was pregnant
with me we got back-to-back pictures of
my mom and my oldest sister back to back
with their bellies out
in a [ __ ] white trash clip
what did your sister have a boy or a
girl
she had a girl so you're it was an uncle
like uh two or three months old
yeah that's your aunt no that's my name
that's his that's me
that's my niece oh my god this is like a
[ __ ] spider web of white trash
uncle tony newspaper at this point i
wouldn't be surprised if i had an aunt
that goes so where did they raise you
did you did your did you just grow up in
the house that your
your mom lived in what what did her
husband say did her husband think that
you were his kid for a while or
uh no they separated almost immediately
uh that was the final like it was like
it was already over over but that was
and they wanted to be done with each
other anyway and it was just an absolute
perfect excuse
so he was gone but he wasn't like he
wasn't
that you know he just wasn't they
weren't getting along anyway so it
wasn't that big of a deal
now the four older brothers and sisters
all
sort of like helped out it was like a
panel of parents but my mom
ran the whole ship and i stayed with my
mom and um
in fact because my father was sort of
connected
and you know wanted to keep things sort
of
uh secret my mom told me
right my mom didn't want me going around
to other kids and bragging about who my
dad was or even just saying not bragging
but you know
mentioning that my dad is blank and
blank you still got to keep your mouth
shut in the family it doesn't matter
a hundred percent and i wasn't a really
i didn't know what was going on at the
time
so when i was a little kid she would
tell me because
my dad would come and visit like he was
cool especially when i was super young
and as i got
as i grew up at all to the point where i
might realize that
this shit's weird and becoming an adult
i think he got less and less
entice fight like he's like good with
kids but like once i started showing
like human qualities he's like oh this
[ __ ]
this guy's going to tell him
yeah but anyway they told me that
my mom told me that my dad uh was
had a different name she said that his
name was like i think it was joe smith
or something like that
and the cia or something
no well that's not what they tell you
believe it or not
i think it was like a truck driver or
something or that's why he's always gone
for
for periods of time got hit by a train
yeah but no he would come and visit
sometimes but the whole thing was that
he was uh
joe smith and that he lived you know
whatever
he doesn't come and visit because he
lives way far away or something like
that
i mean he does visit but it just wasn't
that often that's why yeah twice a week
and did their relationship did their
relationship
continue though like as you were growing
up or did your mom meet somebody new
no my mom uh didn't meet anyone new
around that time
um what ended up happening was that i
think they stopped
i think they stopped [ __ ] like while
she was pregnant with me or
immediately after i was born i'm not
exactly sure but
um he ended up see the big the big move
was with his family because like she
found out somehow they were just they
were done too
but i think she heard rumors of
um there perhaps being another kid and
sort of ended
it was just over he moved on to someone
else anyway he fell in love again
first but let me let me finish this one
interesting part of the
story you guys might want to know is
that so they told me his name's joe
smith and they told me he lived far away
one day and i can't remember it's like
nine ten
eight years old or something like that
i'm on the bus picking up it's like a
morning trip and we're picking up one of
the kids that's on the bus route you
know
and i look across the street of
jeff lewis's house and there is a white
bronco uh that my the same exact car
that my dad drove
so i looked at it and i'm like that
looks like my dad's car so the next time
my dad came
to visit i memorized his license plate
and then on the next bus trip i matched
the bronco to the license plate so that
is how i found out that my father lived
like six blocks away from me my entire
childhood holy [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] nice good for you and
your [ __ ] detective skills too yeah
you were like an
eight-year-old kid cop over here i love
it
well it was crazy because i ended up
asking my mom about it that evening and
it's like a
it was a crazy trashy breakthrough day
for us because she had to explain to me
the entire story i found it out
so young and found out how different i
was and
and uh and you know that shit's just
crazy when your mom's like here's his
real name blah blah blah blah blah
you're italian as hell
um you're you're that he's uh he's this
and that and everything else and here's
why you have to keep it secret here's
what's really going on
and a big part of me thought it was
very cool you know what i mean but also
dude
i mean natural psychology is also like
tells you like oh
your mom just lied the first decade of
your life
yeah in the movie you would grow up to
become the mob boss of [ __ ]
youngstown that's how it would go
you would assume your rightful place at
the [ __ ] table your mom must have
been stunned
that is such an italian thing yeah i
copy down the plate number ma
he made the bronco tony made the bronco
that's such like a [ __ ]
that's such a guinea thing i love it
[ __ ] that is [ __ ]
awesome she would be cracking up if she
could hear you say that because that's
absolutely true we laugh about it almost
every
year about round every christmas time i
bring it up he's out there checking tire
tracks in the driveway
yeah he's licking dirt he was here two
days ago those tracks are fresh
you [ __ ] lied to me wow
that's an enthralling story that's
insane is that common knowledge do
people know that about you
uh uh i mean if they put all the
podcasts that i've ever done together
like the different uh if you lined it
all up
but you know i'm getting straight to the
garbage here that's a [ __ ] story
dude the twist and turns of that thing
is nuts
we've never had anything like that no
that's [ __ ] and also
and another huge factor is that i'm
growing up on the north side of
youngstown which at the exact time that
i was growing up there
it's still one of the poorest capital
country but
when i was growing up it was the crime
capital of
america per capita like detroit and
chicago obviously might have a few more
murders but if you
line up the population of youngstown
with the people that were getting killed
it was something ridiculous i think it
was i think it was we averaged
one a day or something which is crazy
because there's like
i can't remember the exact statistics i
just remember it was
horrible in the uh you know early 90s
mid 90s late night it's been horrible
the whole time
but it was really especially bad so
i'm being raised basically italian white
trash
combo and then all what had become
an all black uh neighborhood that was
getting arsoned out a lot of gangs
because
now they were cracking down on the
italian mob in youngstown
so uh all the black gangs took over and
it became
sort of like a turf war but not really
because the black gangs were just doing
like sort of um different kinds of
crimes than
the italians were doing because uh
goodfellas and all those movies
made the mafia like seem cool
so they cracked down on it i mean that's
why i'm guessing they crack down
i'm not exactly sure but they just
weren't having it back then
so um so that's the crazy neighborhood
that i grew up in it's just
it was just a bunch of like a bunch of
rugrats in the poorest
dirtiest um part of town first
like 13 14 years of my life damn damn
dude the way you explain that
like a sociology teacher or professor or
something like that
that is [ __ ] articulation it's a hell
of a treatment yeah
get someone right in that room no
kidding that's just something that i
would
yeah it's i've had to put the it's
something that you have to reflect on
when it's your dog [ __ ] story
so hold on what'd your mom do for a
living
that's so funny you mentioned that one
thing i was just going to throw in there
was that
another reason my mom and dad stopped
hanging for sure was
just after i was born my mom was going
through a green light
and some guy had just stolen a car a few
blocks away
and t-boned her at like 80 miles an hour
and rolled the car eight or nine times
so it like destroyed her spinal cord
um which was which was pretty rough uh
but she would she would have it would
have been better if she wouldn't have uh
i think she ended up really enjoying
pain pills during that time during the
first
so does the big good part yeah
always set up a sit-down you know what i
mean
um but you know that was then and it
certainly had a lot to do with her back
but um did she go back to work after
that
no she was basically bedridden and she
at the time
was uh running a lot of the entire
numbers operation for all
of that uh
company in youngstown i thought i was
gonna say she worked at the nail counter
at boskovs or something like that
holy [ __ ] dude any
any woman running numbers is a tough
broad
not only was she running it i mean
running it running it she was like
one of the and again i can talk about
this now
because i know for a fact that she would
laugh about it because
i've already talked about it before and
it's silly but
you know she was like uh she was like on
the boss side of things
that yeah really not the thing after
collecting or
even um or even you know
keeping the numbers she was truly doing
it all and at a very high level and with
some people that were
tremendously into those to that level of
uh gambling
and things like that it was easy phone
calls all day
in fact here's a good one i'll tell you
you sparked a good memory
is that [ __ ] when i was a tiny little
kid
yeah saw the house and you know how
obviously you're not gonna have
give someone your real name um
i can't it's okay i'll make up a fake
name but i don't do the actual fake name
that she was and some
[ __ ] guy's son ends up doing the math
that
my mom was anyway so we'll say like you
know say her name was
karen right her name uh you know
in that world would be carrie i guess
we'll just say for example right okay
so one day i'm a little kid and you know
how when you were a little kid and there
were landlines and [ __ ] i don't know you
guys are that you would pick up
yeah phone sometimes to be like cute or
adorable or whatever
sure and uh so the phone's ringing one
day and
let's say my mom's name is karen and
okay
and the person asks for uh they go hello
is carrie there
and i know somebody lives here and i
hung up and
it happened a couple times and
eventually i uh
i said to my mom i go you know hey mom a
bunch of people been calling here lately
asking for somebody
named gary saying they want to put a
nickel on the giants
i swear to god she literally is like
tony if anyone ever calls you're asking
for carrie you put me on the phone and
it stood out to me is so weird even
though i was young i'm like why would
you be carried
and then later on again of course we
figure these things out and also
she's just very like yeah she's very
open and cool about it because they know
they're
just completely out free you know what i
mean it's not like how it is
in youngstown it's not like how it is in
the movies where it's like you you once
you're in you either die
or you go to prison it's you know when
they're cracking when they were cracking
down on stuff during that time
during the real ending part people are
like okay we're
we're out yeah we're getting that figure
or something now was that something that
was in your mom's family like you know
she didn't just start doing that on her
own right i have to assume her
appearance
that was basically what's interesting is
that was basically my dad's version of
child support for her
yeah i'll let you
you're taking over this entire territory
of uh
numbers this is your job now it came
from your dad's side
and was his family his family
was ingrained in the mob like his
parents and it's always
you know it's not always families again
that's another sort of like
misconceptions yeah there's families and
you can be part of a family i mean you
you know if you're there's a lot of
independent people that
are part of a family it's not like a
family thing where it actually runs in
the family that's like
you know godfather levels of stuff i
don't think that's really how it
operates
the last 20 years i mean maybe i'm wrong
[ __ ] man
dude i had no idea about any of this no
idea
well so yeah it's like a hot italian
garbage it's hot italian white trash
garbage
i love it but as far as like your your
upbringing like you know like when you
when you were a little kid when you
think back like you know when you're
looking
you were like you know there was still
like you know there was a home there was
you know cartoons there was
all that kind of stuff right all that
stuff was was pretty much normal
uh no it was pretty trashy so it was um
you know even though again my mom
you know had that what would seem from
the outside to be an unbelievably
uh you know financially beneficial job
it really
wasn't that great she would make sure
that i had a new pair of nikes
when the school year started and she
would make sure that i had a couple new
like outfits but other than that
you know uh it was i would i
there was a lot of pepsi she would let
me drink as much soda as i wanted as a
kid oh yeah
now we're talking four pack we would
always have those on the basement stairs
i feel like when
the mom lets the father slip out of the
child's life
they they over compensate with like
disgusting food
that aren't good lessons they go easy
with the sugar cereal restrictions
yeah oh i mean it's crazy i remember
eating just slices of american that
craft american cheese individual
american cheese
i would just go through it where was
your mom's side of the family where was
your grandparents and cousins and all
that [ __ ] are they in the mix
three out of my four grandparents were
dead when i was born
my one grandma that was allied just
passed away last year at 100 years old
that's my mom's mom
everyone else was already dead because
everybody was having me late you know my
mom i think he's thirsty
he's had me i think my dad was 39
so so you had no like cousins your age
or anything like that
i mean
yeah i had nieces and nephews around my
age but and i also had
my consider my cousins like this whole
group of family that my mom ended up
dating after my dad a whole nother
crazy italian family that was gigantic
and ridiculous and that was
you know we would visit there on like
the holidays and stuff um
and hang out with them so i consider my
cousins that's like the origin story
yeah should be like a master jewel thief
or like a yeah an art thief in europe or
have your own [ __ ]
crew or something or a vigilante you
should you should be batman
technically you really that's a [ __ ]
wild story dude that's the wildest story
we've had thus far
no doubt you said i should be batman
meanwhile i told you earlier my car
almost exactly like that killing the
prophecy
dude the yellow racing stripes is over
the top garbage and i love
every second of it dude that's it's not
real it seems like it but it's not along
the whole side it's just on the two
front divots you got to see it
it seems it sounds more like garbage
than it looks
did your pop ever have a car like that
or was it always like something
indiscreet like the white bronco or
something like that
white bronco black suburban after that
you know it evolved
i remember that's when i was like super
young and having a white bronco back
then was cool i think oj ruined that for
everybody
yeah he put the kibash on the bronco for
a decade at least
a little bit
[Music]
of garbage
another garbage thing about me that i
thought of when i mentioned the pepsi
that my mom would let me drink any
amount of that i wanted was uh
was that she always drank iced tea and
i always just drank soda and
she never really taught me how important
or
yeah how important just drinking a
straight
regular water is oh dude
they didn't even talk about water in the
90s it didn't even exist
i was sprite if you wanted to rehydrate
you drank sprite that's
that's what you did that was like a that
was like a light soda with sprite
i never got like a talk about this from
anyone
and i literally accidentally taught
myself it really only in the past
year did i really learn like oh i
thought water was just like if you
got fat you have to drink water if this
or that but i didn't realize that it
would
mentally at all calm you down or make
you feel good
in any way other than or better than any
beverage i just always thought every
beverage was equal
in fact i thought water was garbage
because it seemed like it was the base
nothing it's got no bubbles no lemon
lime it comes it's free in the kitchen
who the [ __ ] wants that
give me an ice cold screaming pepsi
i swear to god i'm not kidding i'm 36 i
spent the first 35 years of my life
[ __ ] dehydrated and i
had no idea with like tight dry skin and
[ __ ] yeah
and i mean hungover hung over drinking
whatever not realizing like oh water
really just straight water is really the
trick and i would see people
you know out here in l.a and like at
meetings or whatever you know fancy
schmancy [ __ ] and they'd always have
water and i'm like what a boring
douchebag that idiot is
dude remember going to
hey chief let me get a cherry pepsi
stack yeah
remember dude going over someone's house
for dinner and they would give you a
water i'd be like where the [ __ ]
is the coke dude like i'm i'm supposed
to sit here have spaghetti and water
what is this
jail get the [ __ ] out of here it was
always water in a cup with no ice
i [ __ ] savages savages would you rock
the uh would you rock the three liter a
pepsi or
were you a traditional two liter family
definitely done the 3-liter uh you know
i mean that was that was something that
i had i went through it all man i
remember when surge debuted i was like
the only person in line at the birthday
tony
out for a surge yeah like it was a new
pair of uh
kanye's shoes
[Laughter]
that's funny the local news is there
interviewing you waiting in line
crystal clear pepsi oh yeah i was like
i was a disgusting disgusting child
um i used to every uh monday as a kid i
had this
my own routine that i would do where i
would uh you know those frozen like mrs
t's pierogies in the freezer oh
big frozen pierogi family yeah so my mom
taught me my mom found a way to uh get
out of cooking or having any
food needed for mondays at all because
my
tradition was right before pro wrestling
would come on which i think started at
eight
every monday so like seven at 7 30 i
would set up a tv
tray in the living room i would go to a
frying pan i'd put a couple
dollops of all right slice some onions
and i put them
in a frying pan with a couple dollops of
butter and i let those melt down while
the water boils and then you dump the
mrs teas
whole dozen pierogies right in a [ __ ]
pot of boiling water and you throw the
onions and butter on top of the [ __ ]
potato
pierogies when you're done and watch pro
wrestling and he's frozen pierogies with
a giant
pepsi every monday he's like a
nine-year-old sous chef yeah
how old were you how old were you when
you were doing this
again you know not that not 9 10 11 but
i mean we're talking it was young
i remember like it being like up there i
remember like having to sometimes
if you're sauteing onions you're ahead
of your time as a teenager
yeah if you're sauteing onions at 12 to
watch pro wrestling in a tv tray
you're they're a divorced dad at that
point
holy [ __ ] well an interesting fun fact
that i could probably rationalize that
on is that
my father uh is like a world-class
chef that owned his a town owned his own
restaurant as well
and my mom also is like extremely
competitive in that field not
like actually competitive but like for
example
my mom makes such good red regular
spaghetti sauce with like meatballs and
sausage and pork you guys know what
i'm talking here in new york right yeah
of course like
spaghetti sauce i'm starving right now
so
and my father right sorry and my father
like i said has owned an italian
restaurant
my whole life so and
if it's a big deal cooks specifically at
that restaurant my brother
on his side on my father's side
is like one of those whatever as big as
a chef gets
types of chef he ended up being an
executive chef at this fancy joint in
vegas ended up buying the place and now
has a chain of those places in vegas
whatever no big deal but they're
they're crazy cooks they like do it in
their sleep anyway my father has owned
an italian restaurant his whole life
his favorite sauce is my mom's sauce and
basically and i know everybody says this
but i'm gonna say it here
my mom's sauce truly is the best sauce
i've had people over my she actually
sends it out to me regularly here in los
angeles she
she makes it and then she chills it and
then she freezes it
into blocks and then she puts it into a
frozen box and
mails it to me oh my and we'll have a
giant spaghetti dinner
me and my friend we'll just boil noodles
and thawed out and [ __ ] do it
but what i was going to say was is that
my mom never gave my dad the recipe so
one of the
fun things about the relationship is
that he would start craving the sauce
and you know what i mean she would have
you know it was one of those things she
had complete control over him because
he's such a [ __ ]
italian guy that he needed this off
whether he wanted to
[ __ ] or not or whatever or whatever the
situation was eventually he would just
start sweating because
you need to have the sauce once you have
it once you have it regularly
then i hate that woman but god damn it i
love her sauce
she keeps me coming back so so they did
but
so they did cook for you when you were a
kid you weren't you weren't on your own
your mom
your mom was a homemaker to to a degree
to a degree when she did but again you
got to realize that back injury
really really took a huge
toll on her during my childhood it was
quite bizarre so she ended up getting
better as time went on
because i think it was mostly the pain
pills no one i don't think anyone was
talking about it back then you know i
think
you i think something like that happens
in the late 80s and your doctor says hey
take this congratulations have fun it
might be fun
and then you're like what wow oh the
doctor said i can take this this is
[ __ ] crazy
and nobody i think was talking about
addiction or anything back then so i
think that
i think she just had a little bit of
that like touch of like requiem for a
dream like that lady i mean she wasn't
on speed
like that lady that just loses herself
in it and then next thing you know she's
getting more and more and more
and um so it really like mellowed her
out
and then over um you know probably when
i was about
13 14 15 is when she was got a lot more
like
mobile gotcha if that makes sense
because the back injury was one thing
and the pain pill thing was another
so how about your dad's joint did you
get to go and eat there and [ __ ] like
that did you grow up in that restaurant
what no no what the [ __ ] okay so here's
a good one here
here's another
about like the the non-payment of child
support or the numbers ring he's like
you couldn't get a bowl of spaghetti
yeah you couldn't get a [ __ ] you didn't
even i
figured he'd like bring you to work with
them and you'd sit in the corner
they lied to him he said he lived
[ __ ] he was a truck driver joe smith
meanwhile he's three blocks
man a [ __ ] mob owned italian
restaurant that's all i ever want to eat
at
yeah even though i uh even though i did
the math on it
and checked my mom and she told me and
then we had a talk with him and
obviously she told him he knows he
figured it out here's how he did it blah
blah blah
but he never told his family a giant
massive old-school italian family
so it remained just a rumor they had an
idea
you know i told a few of my close close
friends i'm like don't tell anybody but
my dad's actually
and of course they wouldn't ask their
mom like hey mom tony says his dad's
really blah
blah blah blah and they go no he's not
and then they would come back to me like
my mom said that your dad's not really
that guy
and that that prime's like that when
you're a kid that's where it sucks a
little bit
yeah but anyway uh so what's cool
what's here's a crazy here's a crazy one
for you so i'm bartending
i move out to la right after high school
after spending a little bit of time at
college but i moved to l.a almost
immediately
and i long story short run out of money
fast so i have to go back one pound to
save money for
a few months so i pick up uh working
lunch shifts at this other italian
restaurant
um and one day it's rented out for
like one of those banquets it's like a
uh whatever 30-year high school reunion
something like that and i'm bartending
and i'm bartending and i'm slinging
drinks like crazy just
busy as hell you know what can i get you
what can i get you because it's like
open bar or something like that
and um i get to this one lady and i'm
like
what what can i get you and she's
looking at me like she had just seen a
ghost
i mean just completely locked in on my
eyes and she goes
is your father blind and then she said
his name
and i go um and i go
yes and but i knew immediately who it
was
even though i had never seen her or
never met her before and that was
his original wife it was her high school
reunion and when she saw me look at her
bartending this kid
she saw her the man that she fell in
love with yeah
30 years earlier because i look a lot
like what he did when he was younger he
looks like what
his dad looks like it's a very whatever
dominant gene or something like that
and um and so she was really free this
is like days of our lives [ __ ] mob
edition this is nuts so here's what's
interesting
is that is when she said because
obviously she has
she had a lot of control over him
somehow even though they'd been
obviously broken up forever well she's
the mother of his two
actual you know children but she found
it unacceptable that they didn't know me
and that they she was like you need to
come clean with your entire family he
deserves to know
your entire family you need to we're
going to introduce them to his
brother and sister so she's the one that
brought justice to it so i didn't
actually even eat at my father's
restaurant and meet my father's entire
family
until i think it was um
19 or 20 years old
she brought you back in dude we get
shilo the buff to play you i don't
[ __ ] know
meg ryan for the stepmom dude this is
this is a [ __ ] movie let's go
holy [ __ ] so what happened when you met
i forgot i was on a podcast
enthralled by the story i'm like i i i
paint the picture i see you at the ball
it's [ __ ]
so tell us about the first time you
walked into your dad's uh restaurant to
have dinner with the family
well it's funny the first thing that i
noticed was there's like old pictures
old italian pictures in like the hallway
when you first opened the door
and uh and the craziest thing is i
didn't even know that my dad
when i just said that i did earlier i i
said my dad looks like his dad but i
didn't know that
until i look on this wall and one of the
first things i see is this
very clearly i'm guessing had to be
world war one picture is that right what
[ __ ] year was that
30s could have been yeah now 1919 1918
1917
that's where you're talking world war
one so okay then world war ii
that makes more sense yeah
yeah the picture looked old as [ __ ] it
looked older than world war
ii i don't know what it was you've never
seen a family member before
i can imagine yeah and i'll tell you
what the [ __ ] do i know
yeah and i'll tell you what i would have
went back and got one of those [ __ ]
kids that made fun of you for saying
that you were lying
brought his punk ass into the restaurant
and had a couple of goons slapping
around
why i ate [ __ ] ziti to set them
straight yeah the prince has returned
this is like the lion king no
i mean it really is and uh and it was it
was
absolutely unbelievable it was
ridiculous i mean i
did the family accept you oh my god it
was beyond
accepting it was they were over the top
they couldn't believe that they had this
like
you know and i'm telling them like well
that that's cool and all like i'm
ever my answer to everybody was even
though i hadn't even tried it yet i'm
like i'm moving back to los angeles and
i'm going to become a stand-up comedian
and they're like ah that's [ __ ]
great when you're there check out uh
cyril's nightclub
that's a cool thing i remember
specifically is this old lady being like
you have to go to ciro's i was there
when i was a little kid and
or when i was much younger and it's the
best club in all of hollywood and it
turns out of course as you may know
steroids
became the common comedy in 1972 yeah
one of my old italian aunts that i'm
just meeting is like when you get out
there you make sure you go to cereals
you'll have the best night of your life
and i've spent like i don't know
ten to ten thousand plus nights there
since oh my god
that is a [ __ ] i mean you have to
truly imagine
being it's like being drafted to uh
the coolest team in some sport like some
the the yankees of old or the whatever
the you know the miami heat back in that
crazy time like it's like you're joining
an italian family you just got
drafted to a real [ __ ] super
authentic italian family and they're
like hey
it's the weirdest party ever it was like
a super birthday party
wait they actually had a party like they
love you
they had a party welcoming you into the
family
this is insane you have to be writing
this i would assume
i mean it's already it's already written
you know what i mean it's it's it's
it's it's just history it's you can get
nice to play your dad
oh yeah get diced to play your dad
again another absolute funny thing that
you mentioned that because he
is exactly like my dad he talks exactly
like my dad that's exactly
who and what i always thought when even
when i was a kid and i'd see dice on
like hbo or whatever i'm like wow that's
just like my dad
i mean he's not that you know he doesn't
wear like muscle shirts and gloves and
[ __ ] but yeah
you know dyson like i don't know stop
walking around doing nursery rhymes
[Laughter]
your dad's walking up the tables in the
restaurant hickory dickory dock
let me ask you this how is the food at
your old man's joint after all that time
top shelf yeah
absolutely absolutely unbelievable and i
go back there now every year since then
um
around christmas time and he shuts down
you know the whole joints shut down and
i go in there and i can bring
whatever friends or whoever i bring with
me i know where i'm going i know where
i'm going this christmas
that's [ __ ] no i mean really he shuts it
all the way down
and you sit at the bar and he just keeps
bringing out courses
everything except for i never and he
knows this like the one thing i would
never get there is regular
red sauce with meatballs and sausages
because it's just
it's just silly that would be you know
that would be like
um you know the way my mom makes
spaghetti sauce it would be like
[ __ ] if uh pablo escobar did
someone else's cocaine yeah yeah yeah
and he's like no
i'm gay i got i got this at the house
i'm not eating this stepped on [ __ ] you
kidding me yeah
just watered down i can taste the
[ __ ] bacon soda get out of
i mean i here you have to understand i
have [ __ ] gladlock
blocks of my mom's sauce at all times
for the last i've lived out here for
you know continuously now for like 14 or
15 years and there's always an emergency
reserve just in case
all you need is noodles so he still owns
it he still
operates it is that kind of the last
thing that he has that he's that he's
doing
he kept the restaurant after everything
after the dust settled
he just closed it like three or four
weeks ago that's it
the uh pandemic hit hard and he was done
anyway you know he's a he's he's an old
he's an old he's gotta be older yeah and
i was
surprised he didn't close it down sooner
obviously you guys have a pretty solid
relationship now everything has been
somewhat mended to a degree
and
yeah super super cool um
and you're close with your best of ways
like this
yeah this last trip for example i took
my entire podcast crew
with me because we were doing you know
crazy sold out shows we had it routed
columbus
pittsburgh cleveland and youngstown's
right between pittsburgh and cleveland
so uh um
i had uh brian redband and jeremiah
watkins and joel jimenez the
joel and jeremiah the band for we had
jeremiah
yeah oh lovely yeah he's definitely
garbage
yeah he has another wild garbage [ __ ]
there's like
they were like they were doomsday
preppers with like [ __ ]
they were like strapped to the teeth
with guns and [ __ ] he's real midwest
trash
real midwest trash but this last time so
like
we got in what was the order of events
we had a whole day off in youngstown i
set it up that way and what we did was
we hung out in the afternoon with my mom
we rolled up from columbus two and a
half hour drive so we get there
we'll say noon or whatever and we
[ __ ] eat pasta
like you wouldn't believe like i mean
truly
like mounds of this [ __ ] and then you
finish it and you're like well i'm
definitely not gonna have seconds i
don't know why
tony's mom is saying you know when you
get up just get it yourself
the thongs like i'm not gonna need more
pasta than this but
you know everybody does it's crazy you
just have to picture them
i'm sorry we blocked that off on friday
afternoon i stayed at my mom's place
they they were all at a hotel right
around the corner they got the rest up
for a few hours
and then we all went to my dad's place
bottles of red wine galore
peppers and peppers and oil with the
craziest bread that just [ __ ] melts
away
um and then course course course course
course salad
minestrone like you know gourmet
everything
[ __ ] this salad fancy soup fancy
appetizers calamari this that
you know unbelievable pasta dish but
when i when i do eat at my dad's place i
get the uh seafood pasta it's incredible
that is that that's a classy order too
seafood pots
that's a [ __ ] top shelf
and it is but it's a bold order at a
fancy joint or
a house or an italian restaurant because
it's
it's risky business you know you don't
know when the seafood come in
you don't know who's cooking it and
the mixers there's so many things that
can go wrong well that's why it has to
be done so well
but not at your pops though huh sifu
came in today what are you talking about
it's fresh 100 percent he would never in
a million years
yeah that's not something you order at a
diner no one's ordering this that's the
one thing about wise guys they'll do a
lot of [ __ ] but i'll tell you what they
eating ain't eating old [ __ ] seafood
the mussels better be fresh but when it
comes to shellfish mobsters
it's top shelf they're not getting the
day olds it ain't happening
dude how about that and you're [ __ ]
go ahead i'm sorry i'm sorry we got a
little bit of a delay yeah even in that
prison and goodfellas that
size of that ice chest that they have
they pull the [ __ ] big fresh lobsters
yeah
damn i want to hang out with tony's
parents on christmas
and and [ __ ] dude successful stand-up
you're doing a [ __ ] sold-out show
all around that area and you come home
with your whole crew talk about
[ __ ] local redemption story local boy
makes good [ __ ] an
ostracized kid on the [ __ ] playground
didn't know who his family was
everything was kept a [ __ ] secret
when rightfully so you should have been
running the town
at 13. meanwhile you're making your own
[ __ ] pierogies watching wrestling
and look at how that [ __ ] story ends
that's [ __ ] insane and you know
without a doubt that's
without a doubt that's what yeah but
without a doubt the two
are correlated you know what i mean sure
not like
a coincidence i think that if i if i had
obviously normal parents and some
boring normal what people think is a
right childhood then you end up
with what no work ethic no [ __ ] inner
hunger not growing up
fast all that stuff but to mention i'll
throw one more cool thing in there
because
you made me think of it when you're like
what a redemption story what a fun trip
to youngstown was that on top of all
that i had to squeeze in on that first
day on that friday that we got in
i remember now though i dropped those
guys off at the hotel and before going
back to my mom's after
pasta i had to go to the other side of
town and do a podcast
with boom boom mancini who's from
youngstown he's like a god where i'm
from he's the biggest
the biggest deal and he just started his
first ever podcast that's a
very famous boxer that uh
former champion of the world that killed
a man in front of
all of america you guys probably know
this yeah mancini baby of course
you can imagine he's born and raised
from youngstown gave back to the city
when he became a champion he's
literally a god there so the only thing
cooler than all that and having those
magical times and getting to most
importantly share it with a few friends
is going having to run an errand like oh
i'm in youngstown oh i gotta go to
bamboo mancini's podcast yeah that's why
yeah that's just like an
odd sentence to even say yeah yeah it's
like being in washington dc and having
to go do george washington's podcast
that's [ __ ] making it baby i'll tell
you what man i liked you before i
[ __ ]
love you now i'm in your [ __ ] corner
that is a [ __ ]
tale of tales right there holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
how do you not get behind this guy i
[ __ ] i mean
what whoa and i think you know a lot of
the
douchebaggery that i do come across as
and the braggadocious
you know cringe-worthy stuff that i say
and do a lot
is uh is because of as cheesy as it
sounds
that like i know what i've been through
like it's you know
i don't mind playing the bad guy i feel
like i can
always eventually win it back and you
know
sort of play the heel and um enjoy that
part of things because it doesn't get
any wackier than
what i've already been through i want to
open up the movie
all right [ __ ] an exterior shot of
your mom's house in the evening probably
like on a fall day
and we kind of just go into the house it
says youngstown
whatever year and it goes in you can
slowly hear the wrestling
on this [ __ ] small tv you see the tv
stand in the living room with the old
couch and it [ __ ] goes in
and there's a [ __ ] young tony
hinchcliffe
[ __ ] onions making his own [ __ ]
dinner
and then [ __ ] do the juxtaposition
like your dad what's going on with that
and all that stuff and [ __ ] just
build it up from there
oh my god final scene he peels out in a
corvette with yellow racing stripes
[ __ ] you driving down the pch in the
[ __ ] vet
[ __ ] doing 80 with your hair blowing
back
that's [ __ ] and i'm serious you guys
could have
you guys should have seen literally
today there i am flying
southbound on the 101 at 100 miles an
hour
as douchey as it sounds wow
loud music all the way up just having
the time of my life i played golf at
pebble beach this weekend
i found golf four months ago now i'm
addicted to golf
oh yeah look at you
[ __ ] look at it he's also i mean you
know from trash but he's the only guy to
ever wear a collared shirt as a guest on
the podcast
is that a william murray golf shirt
that's classy who's that was that a pig
i don't know i i'm whatever whatever
look good on amazon my friend
amazon amazon anyone who doesn't shop it
for everything on amazon deserves to die
now i could see tony going to the pro
shop at a country club and [ __ ] just
buying it out give me two of those three
of those four of those
take it off the mannequin i need it
let's go i'll catch catch me on the
first tee box
wow holy [ __ ] there's no theme in my
game i do go to those pro shops at fancy
uh
in fancy uh golf courses and i go
straight for the clearance rack
yeah you're garbage you're still gonna
have a little bit in you you know what i
mean yeah
[ __ ] 120 for a shirt get the [ __ ]
outta here
yeah no you can find some good ones
there though you'd be surprised of
course
wow ladies and gentlemen uh what a
[ __ ] episode
what a [ __ ] tale we really didn't get
that i don't
think we got tony yeah one question
because that was just
[ __ ] gripping as i've ever if you if
you
like tony before you gotta love him now
and i don't care who you are
who you know what it is get [ __ ]
behind this [ __ ] buddy
you gotta [ __ ] i'm rooting for you
kid i [ __ ] love that
that was a [ __ ] story fantastic thank
you
ah 100 garbage yeah unfortunately you
are trash yikes
but you are the [ __ ] garbage boss
i'll tell you that right
loss of garbage there you go you [ __ ]
earned it talking about talking about
being the head of the sanitation
department it's [ __ ] tony hinchcliffe
you drive that [ __ ] vet around l.a
blasting dean martin whoever you want
kid you [ __ ] ernie
buddy is there anything you want the uh
anything you want the gang out there to
know other than kill tony what do you
got coming up you getting back out on
the road what's the story
i'd say yeah i've got some dates coming
up in the middle of november going back
to visit austin in dallas for the first
time in a while
and uh other than that i took the rest
of the year off
it's a pretty easy breezy just kill tony
just hanging out with the crew having
fun in a big giant uh
empty main room of the comedy store
normally with 550 people in there and uh
now they're killing about
nine there's about nine people in the
room so we're
we're doing something right yeah
absolutely buddy
[ __ ] the show's unbelievable the
[ __ ] story's unbelievable his podcast
is unbelievable
he's one of the guys [ __ ] charging
through the future in the [ __ ]
entertainment industry
and we could not be more than happy to
have you and hear that [ __ ] tail
buddy thank you so much for [ __ ]
being a part of the show we loved it
yeah man
you guys are absolutely great it was fun
to uh fun to share the story with you
guys are doing great work over there
thank you thank you thanks brother kippy
what do you got uh the folks out there
they got to know before we get out of
here as always just make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and check us out on
that patreon.com
are you garbage yeah so guys the next
time you hear us we'll be coming at you
from uh from our own studio
new digs again we thank gash digital for
everything we love you guys and hope
that you continue on this journey with
us
and hope that you continue to support
gas digital tony one more time thank you
so much buddy
we uh we really appreciate you coming on
we'll see you gang later
peace